es cierto que no es la primera escalada
ni verbal ni militar vimos una similar
el pasado mes de abril pero la retórica
de rusia ha sido especialmente dura en
esta ocasión algunos analistas avisan de
que es posible que moscú se haya cansado
de elsa to work que existe en ucrania de
esa guerra congelada porque ucrania se
está armando cada vez más y está usando
nuevo armamento contra los separatistas
prorrusas por ejemplo drones que le ha
vendido turquía que es un aliado de
rusia en libia pero turquía es miembro
de la otan así que puede cambiar el
balance de fuerzas que hay ahora mismo
en ucrania entre el ejército de kiev y
los separatistas esto es algo que
preocupa a rusia porque es un conflicto
que está muy cerca de su frontera